valeu consigo curso de engenharia
informática
eram várias vezes porque eu estava fazer
aquilo disseram que era difícil senão
que eu não ia conseguir
disseram que era coisa de homens e mesmo
assim eu fui pelo desafio mesmo fui
cheguei na turma era uma turma repleta
de homens - 10% eram meninas com menos
de 10 por cento terminou o curso
fizemos chegou a altura de não marcar
trabalho
todas nós fomos empregadas não tivemos
problemas
falharam os privilegiados por alguma
coisa mas foi assim quando estava nas
minhas equipas de trabalho nas empresas
já estava a trabalhar por ser mulher
havia sentimos que havia uma vantagem
nós conseguimos dar uma contribuição
diferente das coisas vamos fazer aqui o
produto você entregar a entrega fosse
diferente
e foi ali que eu conseguia como será
perceber o da vantagem de ser mulher em
tecnologia
quando chegou a altura de abrir a minha
empresa eu disse eu vou empregar
mulheres em tecnologia eu vou dar
oportunidade a outras mulheres que estão
nessa tecnologia e não tem essa chance e
logo eu tive a chance de empregar
mulheres na área tecnologia eu fiz
infelizmente elas não se adaptaram muito
as áreas técnicas e rapidamente mover as
palavras mais comerciais e
administrativas
quando eu converso com algumas pessoas
que estudaram que estão a estudar
informática fazer o curso de informática
ou então em áreas mais de engenharia
eu noto que isso é uma tendência a
maioria das mulheres estão em áreas
técnicas acabou não trabalharem nas
técnicas vão trabalhando mais em áreas
comerciais ou administrativas que antes
de vir para aqui eu decidi pesquisar um
pouco sobre o que está acontecendo no
mundo sobre as mulheres na informática
olhas tecnologia
engraçado é que há muito pouca aderência
da mulher em tecnologia menos de 18%
menos de 20 por cento o máximo que
consegui foi o que está de 28%
acredito que é pela envolvente que eles
são mais competitivos a europa e ásia
11 12 12% para a áfrica infelizmente não
consegui encontrar registros claros mas
ok
pela minha experiência dá pra ver que é
pouco
só que isso preocupa muito porque porque
está previsto que até daqui a dois anos
e 2020 30% dos recursos humanos vai ser
substituído por máquinas e robôs com a
gente pensa quais são estas profissões
que vão ser substituídas por máquinas de
roubos que já estão a ser substituídas
a gente pode ver exemplos muito claro
que nós vivemos todos os dias
o caixa do banco eu já não vou banco
recepcionistas iniciativas são mulheres
o que nós estamos a fazer por isso eu
tenho uma empresa que desenvolve
softwares e só este ano já vi pelo menos
dez ou mais pessoas serem substituídas
por softwares que nós desenvolvemos
engraçado que é teu cliente outro dia
disse ei outro então já procura uma nova
funcionalidade eles têm até aí não
não queremos demitir mais ninguém é
verdade acontece e isso preocupa muito
porque nós não estamos preocupados não
jogamos por vezes não vejo as pessoas
muito preocupadas
ainda neste mês nessas empresas nessas
instituições
existem pessoas que simplesmente estão
arquivados document estão a processar
dados são coisas muito básicas qualquer
computador pode fazer
então o que nós podemos fazer por isso
a boa nova é que pelo menos também está
previsto que vários chutes empregos
várias outras profissões o o funchal
estão a surgir essa revolução
tecnológica da trazer muitas outras
oportunidades e isso nós temos que
começar a olhar
quais são as oportunidades novas formas
prestar serviço novas formas de fazendo
gols e novas formas de comunicar que
está na hora de repensarmos já foi uma
combinação de trabalhar ea forma como
estão já a fazer o nosso negócio e
quando olhei pra isso eu vejo uma
oportunidade para todos homens mulheres
e principalmente as mulheres
o café é uma das coisas de que as
máquinas não têm máquina não tem empatia
as máquinas não tem criatividade quem
esses são características nossas
mulheres
quem não se preocupe com corrimento ju
são as máquinas então continua a
analisar e nesse processo de
desenvolvimento de software que a gente
faz muita gente senta com o nosso
cliente com quem a gente senta com a
pessoa que vai usar o software ea
maioria das reuniões são feitas
principalmente com mulheres
eu fui perceber que a maioria dos das
funções das funções funcionalidade a
gente desenvolve são desenhadas por
mulheres porque elas dizem exatamente
como querem que aquilo funciona e nós
vamos desenhar e olho aqui pra essa
platéia de quase 80 mulher de hoje aqui
pelo menos 80 software de óptica de 80
soluções consegue sair mas é verdade
eu vou dar um exemplo muito o que
aconteceu também estava lá a numa das
reuniões nós apresentamos uma solução
porque eles queriam que a vez por vez
alertas
nós obviamente podemos alerta que o
verde é porque está perto do amarelo tá
quase vermelho alerta que a pessoa tem
que
tomar alguma atenção algumas são a dona
luiza ela diz que isto não é suficiente
eu quero que este permeio piske nos
vermelho pisca e isso vai ficar o
marketing natal não quero que o senhor
te chama
mas o que o cliente quer e nós vamos
fazer mas a caminho de casa eu resolvi
perguntar ao meu marido tua uma vez
dirigentes do tipo o primeiro piscar
expliquei a situação eu não vou porque
porque incomoda então perguntei qual era
o objetivo da dona luiza que aquele
incomodar alguém tomasse uma ação ou
seja o homem não ia ter esse detalhe
ok eu vi várias mulheres
durante o curso a desenhar e desenvolver
em funções softwares sem qualquer
formação técnica nessa área
é por isso que eu hoje vejo esta
produção tecnológica como a maior
oportunidade para nós mulheres tipo na
nossa criatividade é uma oportunidade
porque a essa tecnologia ela hoje é um
pouco quadrada mas se tivesse aqui o top
a nossa sensibilidade à nossa capacidade
de adaptação a nossa flexibilidade a
nossa intuição aliás quem sabe aqui
veja aqui algumas pessoas da informática
eu sei que sabem que todo o software diz
duas coisas tem um escopo softwares e
intuitivo e amigável
vamos perguntar o homem o que isto
inclui povo
então vamos abraçar esta oportunidade e
vamos vamos vamos olhar para isso como a
maior oportunidade do que o século 21
está a trazer para nós a indústria de
tecnologia precisa de mulheres e precisa
de nós e acho que posso para isso só que
não está a ser explorado
obrigado
[Aplausos]